hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Mario maker ok I'm
gonna try a few more times on this level
totally normal and not du chien sucky
like Ross wants me to do with his own
secret areas come on spit it out and
also I'm switching to the directional
pad because I think I think the joystick
is for chumps there's no way that you
can make the precise jumps that you need
with the directional pad it's not gonna
happen
which is weird cuz you think that it'd
be more accurate but if it's a full of
lies and stupidity
oh god I'm full of lies and stupidity
god dammit ok that was totally my fault
but I got this watch I'm gonna make
progress today you guys are thinking
that maybe I'm not gonna make any
progress but the thing is about that
this is you're wrong and stupid no wait
everybody you're not wrong and stupid I
mean you're handsome and awesome and or
beautiful depending on whatever you I
will die a lonely man abandoned in a
shack in the woods no one's ever gonna
see her oh god why I'm not doing it on
purpose I swear to God I am NOT doing it
on purpose I am NOT what happened to me
oh come on
this is baloney I'm not doing it on
purpose you sacks of crap it's cuz I
switched the directional pad isn't it
you sacks of ass you bags of dicks you
lords of taints I don't know you literal
bucket of pig buttholes cuz you can buy
them in bulk you can buy a pig buck
whole buttholes hey never mind I should
stop talking with concentrate this is
where the game grumps had an advantage
they had someone to talk to and pass off
the insanity I am me and me alone I have
no one to either beat up on or try to
relieve my stress
oh why that was so simple I'm not used
to the direction I should have stuck
with the joystick because I did better
with it now it feels weird and if I
gotta
everyone just you know what I'm gonna
play with my eyes closed and that'll be
a little more hopeful than what I'm
doing right now because I might have no
hope like I said I'm gonna die alone in
a shack in the middle of I'm gonna have
a shack in the middle of Nevada because
you can buy like a thousand acres for
two bucks I'm gonna live there
I'm gonna be all alone as far away from
the ocean as possible the big ocean of
death and people and all of that my
internet beamed up through a satellite
in my blood
no one's gonna live no one's gonna be
none the wiser it's a little too early
for me to lose my sanity I really
thought I was gonna keep my composure a
little better than this
okay I got this enough [ __ ] around
like I said not doing it on purpose but
I'm not gonna let them get to me oh god
damn it
why'd you duck why did you duck well why
were you slower than why were you slower
then you guys saw what I'm talking about
he was a little fleur coming over to
left that time what a bag of asses god
damn it if I don't even get to the
second boss in this goddamn episode then
I'm gonna have a problem I'm gonna have
a problem for the rest of this and then
the rest of my life I'm gonna think
about this lying awakened you see what I
mean I'm Russian
I'm Russian I got a calm down I'm not
rushing I'm half Korean half German but
I'm rushing and I shouldn't be rushing
there's no need to rush because the
mistakes that I make here will spill
over into the rest of my life
and then I'll you know beat my wife no I
want I don't have a wife I'll beat Ryan
let's for goddamn sure okay
dodge the [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] okay yeah
that's scary that's not cool okay so
dodged a hammer bro bro I got this
that's so stupid on my first try when
Ross was showing me this level I got to
the second boss very easily and I didn't
die that soon I don't know why I'm
talking in a mid-atlantic accent but
fool you anybody who thinks it's stupid
anyone who thinks I'm stupid
the double screw you boink okay that's
not right that was that was wrong hey
hey yeah [ __ ] you with your bull I'm
just gonna end you I'm gonna end your
miserable existence Oh timing what
that's what you get think you're trying
to ambush me with my tactics I know what
you're thinking oh you thinking I was
gonna die right then but that's not true
you'd be wrong if no help I'll get this
eventually if I could stop being so gosh
darn twitchy oh god okay I'm okay
I'm a calm I'm a calm little butterfly
floating in a field of I'm a calm little
butterfly voting in a Fiat voting in a
field of flowers this is a pack of asses
why can't I get up there what the hell
there we go god dammit it's about damn
time don't you think you should be a
little less of a douchebag
just a fart you know maybe you should
try it I don't want to question
anybody's lifestyle but you need to stop
being such dick that was too close
okay now this time don't die like a
loser
cuz like a loser is what I've been doing
I can get through this it's easy just
gonna not be greedy yeah and not be
greedy oh he went to the shale right
away huh well how about a little bit
longer by doing this ten years twelve
years how much of my life is our wasted
away on this horrible horrible adventure
how much of my life how much of my life
have I come well what have I brought
what kind of man as I become as has I
haves as I could become this is still
the old god dammit give me up there we
go god I swear that it's it need not be
that hard that's what she said
ok I'm gonna miss it apparently what I'm
gonna carry this point I'm going for the
fire flower because this is a bunch of
[ __ ]
this is a load of ass if ever I seen a
load of ass in my life I've seen many
this is low deist of the loads this
might be the dirtiest load I've ever
laid my eyes I don't know what I'm
talking about this point I just wanted
to fire flower because I can't take this
torture anymore
oh damn it that's hubris that's hubris
that's hubris is that the correct use of
hubris I don't even care it's hubris god
damn it's such a load of ass such a load
of ass ok now that I got this correct I
am going to be a winner so long as I
don't touch the lava which I have
admitted
he died a lot - touching the lava but
not this time
because I am a winner and a winner is me
I'm just gonna burn you just don't care
you're gonna get burnt you think you can
catch fire balls [ __ ] suck down my my
oh well that was it
Oh these fireballs don't do a lot
nevermind I'm just gonna I'm gonna yep
you're gonna go up okay I'm not doing it
on purpose I died I don't think anyone
still believes that I would be doing
this on purpose they they you guys know
by now you guys know by now that I'm
just incompetent and stupid it's Kenneth
get the spring don't know
miss me dick beg all right this time I'm
rocking and I'm a rolling I'm a roll and
I'm a rocking I'm a Moroccan I'll give
it this time this is gonna be the one
there's gonna be the one guys ladies and
gent is gonna be the one I promise you
that there's no way in hell that I'm
gonna fail this time let me see
something here what what happens if I if
I don't grab the spring I bounce off his
head and then bounce off the wall and
then try to get them is that that's a
strategy that's got to be a strategy I
mean I know it's got to be a strategy
I'm sure there's many strategies that I
don't know about here yes yes this is
the rhythm oh yes okay I'm feeling
better I think it's just like a
self-confidence thing like the power
with within me all along but now that I
have a fire flower I feel you know much
better about things I don't know if I
can get my I don't know if I can go my
my doodad to the point where it's gonna
get the other guy speed up and there you
go
well that's a little unnecessary what do
you think you're doing that's right okay
I got this one
see you punks see ya dishes yes I didn't
even need my fire flower I believed in
me the whole time
Oh God not this part ever oh yeah
scheisse okay I got this oh god why oh
god why okay yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
oh god damn it
hmm okay all right I'm gonna try it
without the fire flower once more and if
I if I can do as well as I think I can
do which I think I can do pretty well
then I'm gonna be just fine I'm gonna be
just fine here oh man no oh God don't
mess with me now I pretty sure I can do
this just fine without the fire flower
now if I can do it
because I believe that the power was of
the power was not within me
the power is leaving me Oh God all right
that's all the time and patience I have
for this one so thank you everybody so
much for watching I'll maybe try one
more wavy try one more time with the
fire flower but I think I can do it I
think I can so thank you everybody so
much watching and as always I'll see you
I know you're all out there judging me
please don't like you could do any
better